[Music]
hey guys welcome is check L from Filch's
and today I'm here to talk to you about
sampling bags now what is a sample I'm
glad you asked
sampling bag this is a bag for samples
now what really makes this bag so
special is the fact that it keeps your
sample sterile and it's also able to
withstand a lot of pressure now let's
back it up let's remove the air from the
bag
now there's two ways to secure the bag
there's the boring way then there's the
rebellious way now and don't forget to
close the sides it's clean secure and
they could withstand pressure oh wait
there's more
filter bag she similar to her big sister
the sapling bag except this goes just a
little bit more special she's able to
separate large particulates from dirty
solutions just like the sampling bag you
take their out and they need to cure the
bag so as you can see the large
particulates are separated from the
dirty sample here we have it guys your
two sampling bags secured are tight and
ready for transport